any questions that you have I am hoping
that we will be joined by my colleague
Greg vendra who is one of our senior
software instructors if
not
um oh
swing it so here is
some information about full stack web
development assuming that everyone is
here this evening because you're
interested in a career
in software development full stack
development is how software gets built
today
we've seen over the period of this
pandemic lockdowns the work from home
that more and more
of our world has been migrating into the
digital domain
which means more and more of what we do
is through web apps
mobile apps through web-enabled systems
um so
ability to build full stack
web application gives
potential is world
the systems are more than the sum of
just the front end and the back end of
the database you really have to have a
holistic View
how it all works together
and even if you want to specialize in a
particular
level of the stack if you're a UI ux
developer or if you're a database
administrator it's important to know how
all of the elements work together
so that when somebody comes to you with
a request you understand why they're
asking
um
it's
essential
better skills for
the modern digital economy and it opens
up a lot of different potential career
paths for you
so you can be a full stack developer and
take everything from
the top to the bottom you can specialize
as I mentioned in one of the
different levels of the stack
um
front-end developer or a back-end
developer or database administrator
database designer you can
be a designer of the web app itself
specialize in just the UI ux aspects you
can be a generalized software engineer
software architect
all of these has open to you when you
have
the capabilities of a full stack
developer
that entails
quite a lot of skills so you need to be
familiar with Agile development
project management you need to be
familiar with
Frameworks like spring core
with
disciplines like soap and rest Java and
all of its
uh attendant Technologies and
permutations
and you need to of course understand the
basics of HTML5 and css3 for
this General web designs and it's
important to also understand how web
works with clouds so things like AWS and
Azure are important skills as well so
what I'd like to do now is ask you a
question
allow me to do that
this first question is
why haven't you pursued a program of
this type yet looking at this program
with Caltech and simply learn and
you haven't yet done something similar
so why is that
suppose it if you if you're on out with
streaming service you can put an answer
into the
chat or the comments and we'll get that
back to
me so I can see those information
answers
give you another
under 15 seconds
and here I am
foreign
most popular answer among you is you
don't have practical experience you can
point to and say to an employer this is
what I've done in full stack development
and
here's my experience
um and then about a third of our
audience said can't find a program with
fully comprehensive curriculum that
covers all the skills that I just talked
about so
let me cover how the Caltech program
works and why
it may be the thing you're looking for
so the Caltech postgraduate program in
full stack web development it's a
completely online program it's available
uh worldwide and it has a comprehensive
curriculum
that I'll describe it a little bit later
um it's based on industry aligned
learning path meaning that the skills
that you learn and the sequence you
learn them in builds up a full skill set
for you to be able to take out to an
employer and it's what people in
Industry are looking for people that
they're looking to hire will have the
set of skills that you're going to learn
over the nine month period of the
program
it has integrated labs and Hands-On
projects you don't have to buy anything
Additionally you don't have to have
extra Hardware
um you have an integrated
Jupiter workbench that you can do
projects and
Labs on so it's all there and it's all
through your web browser
don't claim that you can do it all in a
mobile app just yet because it's real
difficult to do a lot of programming on
mobile platform because the screen's so
small but
um a lot of the course content is in
fact available to you to review on
mobile so you can actually do this
24 7 all anytime that you want to get on
and catch up with your projects or or
watch the
Preparatory videos for next week's class
and each week there is a online virtual
classroom
it's usually it's four hour Saturdays
for our Sundays you're live with an
instructor who you can interact with you
can interact with your peers in the
class
yeah
questions answered right on the spot
and
gives you much more than just watching
a self-paced video so
this program
gives you
peer-to-peer interaction it gives you
direct interaction with instructors and
allows you to do your
work during the rest of the week on your
schedule
at the end of it all you get your
certificate which is Caltech
vesting to the fact that you have
completed the court uh courses of this
program that you have demonstrated the
skills that are taught in this program
and that's something that you can show
to an employer and say this
is evidence that I've done this work but
more
um
more than that you have a git portfolio
that you'll leave the program with and
the get portfolio will obtain the
projects you've done including the
all-important Capstone project which
we'll talk about in a bit
uh that shows that you've learned
everything in this program and that you
can use it that you've applied it to
solve a real world full stack web
development problem
if you are in a job industry which
requires you to do continuing education
and prove that to an employer or a
licensing body
Caltech will issue you up to 25
continuing education units
um that's
useful for uh some people who have
professional licenses or other
requirements they need to fulfill
you also get access to the Caltech ctme
Circle
the Celtic ctme circle is an alumni
association for people who have taken
this type of program with Caltech
and
the
at the end of this process when you get
your certificate you'll be invited to an
online convocation with Caltech CTV
program director and
you'll also receive for six months after
the end of the program
for your assistance through simply learn
you are in India specifically I will be
able to provide you with the services
that I'm going to describe in just a
minute
drop a message to the attendees here
also if you have questions for me please
put them into the Q a box in
WebEx or into your comments on the
streaming services
what
all right
yeah
let's talk a little bit about Caltech
and
why Catholic chose to partner with
simply learned Caltech is one of the
world's top universities
consistently ranks in the top five uh it
was founded 130 odd years ago it
the alma mater or many Nobel laureates
many others who
teach there and do their research there
and
Caltech is also the home of
the national jet propulsion Laboratories
recognized as
one of the Premier technological
research and education institutions in
the world
so having a Caltech uh on your resume on
your CV is really something that will
get people uh to notice
they've chosen to partner with simply
learn because of our ability to provide
this kind of learning platform
so to be eligible for this program
you need
to have just some basic things one is a
basic understanding of programming don't
need to be an experienced programmer but
you do need to have some exposure to
programming and programming principles
you need a bachelor's degree it can be
in any field with 50 marks or higher
and some post-graduate program so it's
not suitable for people who are either
still in the University or who have only
a secondary diploma
um it's nice if you have prior working
experience but it is not mandatory for
this program so you can come straight
out of University into this program and
be successful
up
so I'm going to ask you another poll
question here
this second poll question
simply give me an idea of who's in our
Audience by level of experience
while you're doing that
check
in a message a question from Karen until
answer in our q a
if you're watching on the streaming
services please do enter your questions
how to catch this all right
so
the whole result is
about three quarters of our audience are
people who are pressures uh
with less than two years of experience
in the workplace and that's as I said
perfectly ideal for this program
this is a program that will
take you from
the very Basics On Through To an expert
level of full stack web development so
oops
get the poll off the screen
we'll move on
let's talk about how this program
prepares you at this point
fortunately my colleague Greg vendre is
not here
so we won't be able to take you through
the learning
interface of the
platform live and we will be able to do
that in a future session if you'd like
but we can also arrange for that but the
learning environment includes your
ability to manage your curriculum
show you which courses are in your
program which one is unlocked for you at
the moment because we'll go through them
in a specific sequence and they unlock
one after the other you'll have live
virtual classrooms where you take
lectures from your instructors and can
interact with them live ask them
questions do exercise with eye exercises
with them live you'll be able to do
tests and labs
be able to do projects including the
Capstone project which I'll describe
momentarily
and the system will monitor tracking it
will unlock
each course and give you proof of
completion at each one and then once
you've completed your Capstone project
successfully it'll unlock your final
certificate
which you can then
present to employers along the way you
have 24 7 support you have the ability
to message your instructor you have the
ability to chat in the community with
your fellow students
message our support Personnel both for
technical problems with the platform if
you have any or with technical questions
about the program content and we'll have
people available 24 7 to field those
questions for you so
this is something that you can actually
do on your own schedule throughout the
week
let's talk about how we build up
this
program you need
step-by-step manner and
you start off
with the orientation session for the
full stack web development which is
pretty straightforward online session
um that's just to give you the
expectations of what the course will
contain and Orient you to the learning
management system and how to use it and
then you move into your first course
your first course includes live
instruction as do all the rest
uh you'll do object-oriented programming
uh using Java you'll learn about data
structures in this first course then
you'll move on to understanding back-end
processing
how the
server works in the client server
environment you'll be looking at
Frameworks
um
such as spring in the devops kind of
environment devops being
a very critical part of modern software
development and deployment
the way that
holsak
web apps are delivered pushed out to the
world
then you'll develop a web application
front to back
focusing on the front end in this
fourth module of the program
and finally Capstone project
where you'll tie all these skills
together and develop a full stack
application that includes front-end
back-end database all the different
services and interfaces
and
along the way you can take
electives which are at no additional
cost
electives are available to you at your
choice if you're interested in them
and the electives consist of
master classes with Caltech instructors
covering different topics in full stack
development as well as testing in the
devops life cycle
throughout this program you're going to
be learning different tools
libraries and platforms
um
angular spring docker
Jenkins Maven you'll be learning about
the principles of containerization
um scalability
SQL and not SQL databases and how to
build your get a portfolio
and so all of that
is covered in the program but also you
get hands-on experience with each of
these tools and platforms
so that don't just
understand it from an intellectual
standpoint but you understand it from a
Hands-On working standpoint and
demonstrate to yourself and others that
you know how to use the tools
then you tie that all together
into your Capstone project Capstone
project
allows you to showcase the your future
employers the work that you've done in
this program
demonstrate to them that you are a full
stack web developer
but you'll be given a price of different
problems in different domains of
different types of web applications
full stack
web systems develop they're different
applications
you pick one that interests you
and you'll spend several weeks working
with your instructor
coming up with the design and
implementing that design
show off as your final project in the
course
and
it's takes several weeks three to four
weeks it's
you have to be able to show that it
works from every aspect from every angle
it will be graded in that and your
ability to
earn a certificate depends on your
ability to complete this Capstone
project successfully so it's serious
work
um but again at the end you get to show
this off
to your future employers
say this is the kind of work I have done
and the quality work that I've done
so this is a really important aspect of
our
postgraduate programs
we have
partner advisors from Caltech ctme
to direct the curriculum
who manage the instructors for our
master classes
and who will be recognizing you at the
convocation when you earn your
certificate
Rick Hefner is the overall program
director for the Caltech
uh
Technical and management education
program and he's also a
experienced in the industry
David
also experienced software entrepreneur
and he is an advising professor in the
program the one thing that you notice
about
Caltech program
is that the
instructors from Caltech as well as from
simpler and courses are all industry
experienced people
uh
just textbook learning people who have
done this working industry and can show
you how it's really
accomplished
let's talk a little bit about the
learner outcomes
so people come to this program from
different Industries certainly from
Information Technology from software but
also Banking and finance and from every
other
segment of Industry because
as I mentioned
we live in a digital world now
especially over the last couple of years
every industry has had to develop
much more capability
with web applications even just to
support
work from home and remote work
the every company every industry needs
people with full stack web development
capabilities and that's why we bring in
people from Aerospace and from uh
manufacturing industries
from Finance from high tech from
e-commerce
and the
I'd like to talk now about
the job assist program which we provide
specifically in India sorry if you are
watching from
another country we don't yet offer job
assist outside of India or the United
States
but um
let me describe for our Indian
viewers today
what this consists of you have access to
of course our
webinars and career events that allow
you to keep up with your career on an
ongoing basis
have the ability to do your real world
projects within this course and then the
job assist services that we do with our
partner IIM jobs
be the services that you get for six
months after you complete the program
after you receive your certificate you
have six months to use these Services
let's talk about what they are you have
access to the IIM jobs Pro portal
which gives you exclusive access to a
certain number of jobs in their player
Network gives you early access I should
say not exclusive
um
it gives you some job search tools that
are very helpful in binding those
specific job that you might want and it
gives you complete discretion and
privacy so that if you are considering
changing players your current employer
won't know
you also get a resume and review rewrite
service which is extremely important
today because
nowadays resumes go through automated
artificial intelligence screening before
they ever see a human being so
important to understand how to construct
your resume how to word your resume how
to format your resume in order to be
able to pass through that first level of
AI bot screening
and still be attractive
the the human evaluators who will see it
once you've made that first cut so
uh we'll work with a resume writer
you'll have a couple of rounds where you
can
go back rewrite your resume reformat it
use the right keywords highlight your
capabilities and experience
that
gets you a resume that will put your
experience and capabilities
in the best light
you also get one-on-one interview
preparation service
and this is important because once you
get past the screening of your resume
you'll need to talk to human beings and
it's important therefore to have
experience and practice in what kinds of
questions you're going to be asked and
how to present yourself
uh what kind of interactions you should
have
with people in the different levels of
interview that you're going to be taking
you'll be taking
technical interviews that'll focus on
your skills you'll be taking
um more
organizational fit interviews which will
focus on how well you work with a team
these will come from different levels
you may have to do
four or five interviews to get to the
job offer that you want so and that's
within the one company you're applying
for
um and multiply that by all the
different
companies that you may end up
interviewing with so
interviewing is an important skill to
have and to practice and that's a
valuable aspect of our job assist
program
mentioned we have
theories of
webinars
that cover industry topics that cover
technology topics we have master classes
and different
software development aspects techniques
how to build a particular kind of app we
have
career advice on how to
get the most out of job boards or how to
structure your job search things of that
nature so these are all available to you
on an ongoing basis
a career on track as your
proceeding
and with that I'm going to ask
this question
based on what you've heard so far
all right
are you interested in enrolling in the
full stack
web development program
while you're answering I'm going to
check to see the messages that have come
in
okay
foreign
so 90 of the people attending today said
that uh they're interested
in joining this program and that's great
I'm going to share with you how to do
that
that was one of the questions that I saw
come in
how do I get started
so the enrollment steps are very
straightforward
going to put into the chat right now
um
how to contact ask us at simplylearn.net
and what this will do is I'll put you in
touch with our learning Consultants
any Consultants will answer any
final questions you have about the
program but they'll also be able to get
you started with your application so in
the chat right now you'll see that email
address as well as the link to the
program home page where there's
information and things you can download
for the syllabus to review
and
once you've submitted the application
through ask us at simplylearn.net
schedule an application review where
Caltech will review your qualifications
verify that you have your bachelor's
degree
um
do maybe a small assessment test of your
programming
uh capabilities again remember that you
don't have to be a programmer you don't
have to expert programmer
to be familiar with programming Concepts
and
um
we have a number of free courses that
are available to help you prepare for
that so there's a lot of
ability for people who are just starting
in the industry to get into this program
get remedial courses for anything that
they haven't caught up with yet
ultimately once the application is
approved you'll get a mission letter
and at that point you'll schedule for
your
Program start so here's the program
schedule and also the cost of the
program
in rupees
the next welcome session is October 11th
that's that preliminary
session for the course the actual
classes start
oops sorry uh December 3rd
and that'll be the first live class for
this upcoming cohort again
program is a nine month program
and
the course cost is one lock ninety
thousand
it can be financed with the zero
interest financing at sixty three
hundred and seven
rupee a month and
again you want to reach out to ask us at
simplylearn.net
those of you who are in our live session
today you want to ask them about a
promotional offer for being here at
this webinar
that's their gift to you for
being here and listening to my
presentation so
with that I'm going to go into the
question and answer period
I'm going to stop sharing my screen
because you don't need to stare at that
slide
when you can be staring at me
so let me bring up a couple of questions
that have come in so far and if you have
additional questions now would be the
time to put them in the Q a
um
so here and we just have a couple I can
see here Karen asks is there an online
exam to get certified
and the answer to that Karen is this is
an online program in which
um each course
has a set of weekly
labs and projects that you must do
you have uh
course and
evaluation and exam for each of the main
modules in the course so
after that first online uh orientation
there are four main modules in the
course and each of those has a
course Capstone if you will a final
project that your evaluation and
graduation are from that course
and that unlocks your next course so you
can't complete
unless you complete the course you're in
successfully you can't go on to the next
course
that is how we make sure that by the end
of the program once you've completed the
Capstone that you have demonstrated that
you have all of the skills and knowledge
um for Caltech to be able to certify
that you are qualified as a full stack
web developer but when you say online
exam no there isn't an online exam where
you have to sit for a licensing body or
a industry vendor or that type of thing
it's not exiting figure
uh for your Microsoft Azure
administrator exam
um but the entire program is online and
that consists of a ongoing series of
projects Labs evaluations and tests so I
hope that answers your question Muhammad
asks is this program really only for
people in India and no that is not the
case Muhammad is open to people uh
pretty much around the world
and simple learn operates in
well over a hundred countries right now
we offer this online fully online
program so it's accessible for anywhere
and so
yes you can take this program from
anywhere I don't want to ask
folks that ask us at simplylearn.net
what the program cost is in your local
um
region or country
the only thing that's different is that
in India we do offer the job assist
program
we don't offer that
other countries like Middle East Africa
Asia
Europe
how much is this whole stack program in
dollars
are there no scholarships or bursaries
um
so
again zika is true there are no
scholarships or bursaries unfortunately
but you can if you go to the website for
your and
localize it to your country you'll see
what the
program costs
or area is usually dominated dollars at
that point
um
we designed this program
for Learners outside the U.S
because Caltech is a U.S University and
it has a separate set of programs
for its domestic audience in the United
States so this is a separate program for
people in the rest of the world
so
we being
a company with a large operation in
India we focus on some aspects of the
Indian market but again you'll be able
to see what the local price is either by
asking us to ask us at september.net
we're going to the program page
then we have another question
from uh Gotti who asks is this a job
guarantee program
and I am going to tell you no it is not
a job guarantee program Jyoti is
um
a program with job assistance for people
in India we do not guarantee that you
will find a job from this program to do
that we would have to have arrangements
with employers
there are a number of different
competitor programs in the market where
people say
oh we guarantee that you'll get a job
um or your money back and
simply learn doesn't operate in that
sense because what those programs are
doing are they're saying we expect that
the job market is so hot right now that
if you go out you'll find a job and
we're willing to take that risk
um simply learn would only offer a job
guarantee
when we have arrangements with actual
employers who have told us they will
hire the people who graduate from those
programs so we have a
very strict policy that we don't offer a
job guarantee for this type of
postgraduate program with our University
partners because that would be
overselling and over promising
however
with the qualifications that you get in
this program and with the fact that it's
certified by Caltech which again is one
of the top five universities in the
world
um this makes finding a job as a full
stack web developer
much much easier for you because you
have this qualification
so
I have another question from
excuse me it's like Lean Forward I
thread you um I just wanted to make sure
I got your name right on the project
it's uh I probably just mangled it
anyway but do you pay monthly on Emi
after placement that is one option I
showed you on the
pricing slide that you have the option
to finance this monthly at zero cost
financing
uh so you have that
uh option and we learn basic things
through this platform it all asks
and I will say yes you can learn very
basic things this program will as I said
start off assuming that you know only
the basics
of programming
um
we do have on the simplylearn.com
website
a number of different courses some of
them free some of them paid that cover
software development skills so you can
gain that basic knowledge from those but
if you enroll in this program if you're
accepted into it you can be assured that
you will have access to all the tools
you need to learn the basics that will
take you through each course in the
program
and develop you beyond the basic level
to the expert
level
which language is mainly used again this
uh
you can see sorry
um
instruction is mainly in English
that's so that we can draw address the
widest possible audience worldwide
we haven't yet developed
language other language courses
but that is something that may happen in
the future I cannot guarantee that
uh It'll ask again
how much you have to pay at starting the
course uh that is a question for the
folks that ask us at simplylearn.net
they will be able to tell you what the
payment terms are to get started
and
let me check a few other questions
because I'm looking at the chat and I
want to look at the Q a window
I don't have a bachelor's degree can I
apply
um
so this one unfortunately for this
program you cannot apply to this program
for uh
without a bachelor's degree is a
postgraduate program
that's a standard set by our partner
Caltech
and so it's very important
that we uphold that requirement you
don't have a bachelor's degree and
you're looking for other training
options you can check the
simplycenter.com website
see what other options we have for you
um
and just like you said here in Pakistan
can you apply you certainly can apply to
our other programs
um if you have a bachelor's if you earn
a bachelor's degree you can apply to
this program from Pakistan there's
another limitation there
and
some people are asking if this webinar
has a proof of attendance certificate
that's not something that we do for our
program preview webinars think I showed
a slide that showed a number of the
other webinars that simply learned
provides for career support for
technological subjects for an overview
of the industry that type of thing and
so for those other educational webinars
which are all free
um and open to the public you can you
will receive proof of attendance
certificates for those but we don't do
that for this type of webinar
um looking to see if there's any more
questions there's just
a couple more are there any on-campus
places
uh now I've heard you there are no
on-campus placements
um
however Caltech is
discussed with us in future allowing
Chromecast on campus visits if you
happen to come to Southern California
and want to see the campus and we could
probably arrange that
with uh
with Rick Hefner
and
last question I'll take is From Austin
who asked for financial aid again Austin
don't have a financial related program
for this we do have the
financing to make it as affordable as
possible on an ongoing basis
and
just to say to if the heart are there
programs on simply learning for people
who are doing their bachelor's there are
there are I would
recommend if you go to our link for this
program page and you can
browse through if you find that this
isn't
a program for you you can check to see
if there are other programs available
but we certainly encourage you if you
have a bachelor's degree and are looking
to become a full stack web developer
to look at this program
and
enroll with us Caltech again has
an unparalleled reputation
and
the academic world
vtme program at Caltech is
well known among the industry
because it responded to an industry
demand where people
various companies in Southern California
went to Caltech and said you know our
people need technology training
management education and Caltech
responded by creating their ctme
division in
we're very proud to be working with them
and again we recommend this as a great
way to start your career we'll stack web
development I'm going to ask one last
question
and close off
presentation today
and that is for those of you who are
interested
I'd like to start when would you like to
start so
very straightforward question
how soon would you plan to enroll is
this something that you want to do for
that upcoming
cohort that's starting with the
introductory class on October 11th in
the
first live classes December 3rd
something that you might want to do soon
after that it's something that you're
looking to do maybe sometime in the
future because you need to continue
uh finishing your degree that type of
thing so let me show you what the result
is
uh forty percent are interested in
enrolling immediately again we have
a discount offer for people who want to
enroll in are willing to enroll in that
October 11th cohort
um about 22 additionally I'm looking to
do it maybe the next cohort after that
or so and then we have about a third of
our audience are people who are looking
through this more than six months out so
rest assured that we will be here
Caltech has been a partner with simple
learner for several years now and the
number of different programs that we
offer with Caltech has been consistently
growing so we can
pretty confidently state that
this is something that you want to do
next year the year after when you get
your degree we will be here to help you
and with that I'm going to
thank you all for being here today
I want to um
express my appreciation uh uh I also
want to apologize for not having my
colleague here to do the live
demonstration of the uh
platform
um at an unavoidable scheduling conflict
called him away
which is something that happens when you
were working with people who work in
industry and who um our senior
instructors with our uh
courses come first so apologize for that
but I do thank you all for being here
and I want to remind you again
to contact us and ask us at
simplylearn.net
information I'll put again into the chat
for you
give you a couple moments to um
collect that email address and that web
link meantime
our final thanks and
have a great evening look forward to
seeing you in our simply learning
learning community